the voicemail number for the show is two
one nine two david p here's another song
submitted to the david pakman show take
a listen to this one hello well hello
david it's so nice to have you back on
your youtube show you're lookin swell
[Music]
yes very good thank you i don't know if
that is supposed to be made also into a
dubstep EDM remix but at this point the
questions around whether these are
satirical songs or not are only growing
and thank you for the submission i
appreciate it is this may is this the
best singer from our audience so far
that a submitted a song that is my
question to you we've got a great bonus
show for you today four hundred and
fifty thousand people applied for andrew
Yang's thousand dollar a month offer
that he announced at the presidential
debate last week we will also talk more
about donald trump looking to turn New
Mexico red and Arizona's Supreme Court
has greenlit discrimination against
against same-sex weddings all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
I implore you to join me there by
becoming a member at join pakman.com or
a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show